I'm coming coming I'm coming I'm coming
next hey guys I'm Ryan Wright hi there
I'm Veronica a dick or a dick the one
has created another video called
reactors leek intro a parody of Justice
League Unlimited
intro I am not familiar with the Justice
League Unlimited intro but I'm sure this
will still rock my socks
this time I'm gonna be been in on
Superman but really I should be done
Alyssa jinx
Brandee there are your Wonderwoman a
caution a Kisan sweet you know that
would be a cool movie we want more we
want more
come on a dick I don't want to listen to
that right now I'm stoked
Tyrone's favorite superhero of a
Superman - Batman and he switched us
although Superman in great Superman is
the leader though so I guess that makes
me top dog now in about subscriber count
no more it's about a day dick the ones
cartoon mashups that determine whether
or not I'm number one right I'm number
one
so does that mean me like we're the top
two you're like the top woman you're
Wonder Woman baby Wonder Woman and
Superman [__] that's why he made me
Superman we yeah we do stuff anyway guys
thank you a dick the one keep making
more keep making more and keep making
more great call next time I'm Batman
she's Catwoman okay if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Veronica's
channel there's a lot of acoustic covers
on there it's really awesome [__] I'm
serious do it and if you follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter might get
enough followers where we could get
product placement but instead of making
a product placements xgo today I wanted
to give a shout out to some of the most
consistent people on the social networks
of YouTube Facebook Twitter I wrote a
list of the ones who are always
interacting
these aren't gonna be long shoutouts but
Michael D Stewart is always on the
Instagram
thanks a lot dog savanah wild crazy ass
woman she is on the Twitter epic ace is
on the Twitter
this dude is because doing a short time
with the shout outs I can't shout out
everyone than Adamic this has been
requested on the Facebook page my house
raw Maheshwara bin
anyway he's on like every social network
constantly commenting dude right now I
think here in the top lead my friend
you're in the top Josiah tire and you
chef ashraf art constantly like one of
the first people to comment on the
youtube channel so thank you to and
jiggly jelly like he is the one of those
people who makes late appearances now
but when he does he checks out
everything checks out every single thing
comments on everything so thank you guys
you guys [__] Rock this is a genuine
sincere shoutout I'm not gonna mention
dick [__] [__] or anything like
that cuz this shout-out is genuine from
the heart yeah [__] yeah I'm his hype
girl what gonna help it had to be done
it had to be done